so one of the biggest and most formative
setbacks in my career actually happened
senior year of college I had started a
company called my mobile menu or mmm
with my best friend Steve and we had
applied to this brand new program called
Y Combinator back then this was a whole
new thing today obviously it's the
institution for startups but we were so
excited and we went up to interview with
them in Boston and gave the interview of
our lives just nailed it we were gonna
change the world mmm right no one was
gonna wait in line again because you
could just order from your phone that
night we got the phone call from Y
Combinator and they told us that we were
rejected which sucked and we got drunk
and the next morning with hangovers on a
long train ride back to Virginia we got
a call from Y Combinator from Paul
Graham and I picked up the phone and he
said listen we still don't like your
idea but we like you guys and if you're
willing to change your idea just scrap
that mm whatever ordering thing come up
with something new we'll fund you and we
got off at the very first train stop and
he was Connecticut got on the first
train back to Boston met with Paul and
spent an hour with him just
brainstorming and what came out of that
meeting was what would become reddit
which is today the ninth most traffic
site in the United States and came on
the heels of one of my first and biggest
career setbacks and and obviously one
that I'm grateful for